thing about being a trained fighter you
have that confidence because you know
what you can do
you know and i think like when you know
when you're younger you would scrap with
anybody right but there's a difference
when
the train fighter puts their hands on
you so when i was started kickboxing
and in my mind i'm like i'm [ __ ]
tight okay yeah
like how many weeks have you been doing
i'm talking about well when i thought i
was tight yeah that was day one
he said how are you doing he's like yeah
and then i remember all i needed was
some mitts there's this video that i
recorded of myself and i put it up
and i remember right before i posted it
up i'm like yo why is this [ __ ] in slow
motion though
like i'm like i'm way faster than this
yeah but it puts in perspective how
cocky people are about their skills and
specifically when it comes to fighting
right
fighting probably the worst because you
gotta have confidence yeah and i also
found out too when i
when i started training more often
there's people who have trained long
but they're also people who have trained
long and they suck yes i didn't know
this right so a lot of people would talk
big and i'm sitting here just absorbing
all these stories
but the thing about fighting that i
found out too which is awesome is
because it's such an honest sport you
could talk as much as you want
when you're on that mat it doesn't
[ __ ] matter it's the same as stand up
oh you're wrong
oh he sucks or this this like is the
crowd laughing like
there's no it's very black and white
yeah very black it's super honest
so so sports and that it fighting has
this weird because everyone's been in a
fight so everyone thinks they can do it
yeah but you don't hear
anybody like now your boy's like dude i
would [ __ ] lebron up man
you like no one talks like no one says
like man i would cross kyrie up so
[ __ ] bad
forever but fighting people i hear it
all the time
dog if i just get in there with floyd
man one [ __ ] chick that's all i need
is one bro you
ain't gonna do [ __ ] and it's uh
i think for me because i was trained for
like six years i was in the ufc
and they brought in the denver broncos
wanted to train with me and shane carwin
who was the heavyweight champion at the
time and i was like ranked like number
11 or 10 in the world
so the broncos came in you're talking
diesel d lyman's linebackers
and they you you heard them before like
man these guys ain't [ __ ] they they
might know the technique but
[ __ ] toss them like this oh really no
[ __ ] clue we get in there and they
got rolled up so [ __ ] fast they don't
have that
and they were just like oh my god i'm
like and you guys are at this level
think of
average joe they think they can do the
same [ __ ] and you guys
are the 0.01 of the population and you
think like this
like we had no idea i'm like yeah [ __ ]
the like the i
the fight iq part is crazy right the the
the part where you have to be very
repetitious
in drills and sparring and then your
fight iq goes up without you even
noticing it i think like the
the hard part about kickboxing for me
was there's no belt system so you don't
know until you get hit in the face about
how how great you are
like your fight iq just starts to level
up as you continue to do this repetition
and so like i remember when i first
sparred like i didn't realize that i
flinched a lot
that's the first thing that people do
like you just when you it's natural yeah
that's not
one of these right natural and i just
couldn't it was frustrating because i
couldn't figure out how not to do it and
it was just to get punched in the face
more
yeah and then it's the only way you get
used to it you just it's like oh you
didn't die yeah
and so you start to get over it here and
there you know and i actually remember
when uh me and my buddy adam were
watching a specific ufc fight and i
[ __ ] hated you you know why wow
you knocked out my hero krokob yep you
but here's my thing with that he was my
hero
i hated myself i dude i apologized to
him in the back
really oh yeah i was like dude i'm so
sorry and he
he's and i he's still my favorite
fighter of all time
he's the reason why i got the sport
because me and him went attitude
and he broke my nose and then it was a
good fight it was a great fight and i
got a knockout bonus
and then i'm looking at him he's this
[ __ ] walking
legend dude legend and he's so
[ __ ] up and he like doesn't know where
he's at and he has his weird fanny pack
on
i'm all [ __ ] up and i just look at him
i go dude
there has to be more to life than this
man like what are we doing i was like i
love you man i just [ __ ] starched you
out there
then this is for money i'm like this is
stupid
and he just looks at me with his broken
english goes this is life
and i was like it's not though dude this
ain't for me that's when i was like this
isn't for me
oh you thought about that that early on
and you still continue to fight as soon
as after
as soon as that fight ended i looked at
my team i'm like dude i don't want to do
this man
do you think that that fight was the
reason why like your your
your your fight record got a little
splotchy because you didn't feel it
right here because i don't think
i mean in my personal opinion right
anybody that's a heavyweight in like
you're top ten
if you're a top 10 heavyweight fighter
in my personal opinion just from you
know
i've seen you since i was a kid i feel
like top 10 everybody has it it's a
mentality
point at that you're 100 okay yeah but
um
the thing that with me i was almost like
a cheat code in a video game where
i didn't have the experience or the
skills but i was playing at the hardest
level
so i got by my athleticism but i have
the experience so i got to a certain
level even that cro cop fight was a war
man
yeah we're real realistic i probably
should take him out earlier than that
but there's a war because he's a [ __ ]
savvy vet he's seen a big athletic kid
so then
you get so i beat gonzaga before him i
started in three rounds and then gonzaga
[ __ ] stars
yeah i beat the [ __ ] out of gonzaga so
he's ranked like 11. so i start gonzaga
put on a boxing clinic i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's cool then i get crow cop i'm like
holy [ __ ] my hero starch him
and then again it's this cheat code
where i got basically i got thrown to
the main event right away and i was at
maine a main event experience
and then i started fighting nogueras and
rothwells and these monsters who were
like oh big athletic kid with a heavy
right hand
cool we've seen this before and then i
just wasn't ready for the moment
so then it was and then also my heart's
not fully into it
and i feel bad like my number one thing
with my coaches i was talking with my
coach the other day about this
he's like man if you just had a mean
streak you've been world champion
he was like you're always too nice to
everybody you're always too nice man in
the gym you're too nice
i was like i don't want to hurt people
dude it's not worth it to me like i'd
rather do other [ __ ] man i was the same
way
that's so interesting the same way yeah
explain yourself please
which is a huge fight for me and he went
on to great things i submitted him in
the first round
first anaconda choke ever by heavyweight
first round
he was my friend man i cared about matt
so like
he was like oh let's talk [ __ ] to each
other and i'm like i don't want to do
this dude i care about you
he's like oh this is what we got to do
i'm like this sucks dude because we're
elephants in the circus
because i never understood like even now
from an outside perspective where
people will go to war they'll literally
bash your [ __ ] face in
and then they're hugging after i'm like
dude touch me you
you try to kill me you know but it's it
it's kind of like
uh with comics like if you're a torn
comic like you know that road work grind
so when you see each other in an airport
even if you don't know each other but
you're familiar with each other
you bond because you've gone through the
same [ __ ]
so it's like you know guys that serve in
war together they have this bond that's
unbreakable so like
my last fight when i fought trash brown
he [ __ ] hated me i used to date his
ex-girlfriend he
hated me his team hated me after the
fight he came my locker room was like
you're right man
because you have that weird like we both
went through awful [ __ ]
and we and we got it done and you know
and that there's
there's this weird respect got it yeah
it's it's
how do you how would you like handle
like for example right um
because i follow you you have some of
the most worst comments
that i've ever read in my life for a
very successful platform right
um and i always found this very odd is
when people question
your fight iq even though you've been a
top 10 heavyweight
and they want to tell you how fight
works right yeah sure is that annoying
for you i don't see it dude
because it annoys me you know
that's what i signed up for like it's
like on the platforms i'm on the voice
that i have
of course you can get backlash like if
you go to drake and i'm not saying i'm
at their level but if you go to drake's
comments or kevin hart's
lebrons they're getting hate but they're
not hate on me because i'm not
successful
you know what i'm saying like if i
wasn't doing [ __ ] they wouldn't be
hating
my level of success brings that and i'm
not even nowhere the hates only get
worse
because i'm just getting started yeah
i'm launching thick boys studios in june
like i have so much [ __ ] going on
and even bigger announcements like oh if
you guys are hating on this
geez man wait dc what i do so
it's just good and i don't see i don't
see any of it dude i look at my bank
account i make sure my family's right
and i look at my uh touring ticket sales
as i don't look at numbers for podcasts
i'll get nothing
that's smart and i look at my bank up
see how my ads are doing everything good
good good cool man
i don't see social media dude i don't
see any of it i post i get out
yeah yeah yeah i think that's just good
like your heroes growing up didn't have
social media like can you imagine if
richard pryor had social media
or if michael jordan did or if michael's
doing a daily podcast it could be a
nightmare i'll be interested in comments
being a nightmare it's it's i feel i
feel bad for kids though you know
i do too this is the world that they
grow up in and uh i was talking to my
friend uh her kid
is a sophomore in high school and she
was telling me that kids now
your popularity isn't based on what you
do in school is what you do outside of
school isn't that a bummer
so it's based on your social media
following are you serious that's why i
was a fan when they were gonna get rid
of
followers so people can see i'm like oh
that's so great for the youth but then
they didn't
they didn't do it because i don't know
but also back to the haters dude i've
never ever in my life ever out of all
the hate that i get
i've never had someone doing better than
me hate on me ever in my life
and that was really smart isn't that
weird never i never thought i've never
had bill burr talk [ __ ] to me joe rogan
no let me go delete all my comments i'm
just talking
about people i'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] ass
mother [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] but you're not
going to punch down you know you're not
going to be like
find some random dude and talk [ __ ] to
him it's just if you're doing something
yeah you just
just come to the territory i tell these
guys all the time dude social media is
not
real man that's not the real world
people have polarizing comments on there
and they're trying to get attention
so they post the most wild [ __ ] i see
any of those people in the street
oh let me get a picture man i'm gonna do
this yeah yeah um the thick boy merch oh
it sucks yeah i sell out every time and
you have it on
yeah i i feel like for me too mentality
wise i started to understand that when
because when i was younger
everybody used to love dane cook right i
hated his stand-up
and what i used to say which was false
was like oh he's not funny he said well
he if he's not funny how the [ __ ] is he
selling out madison square garden yeah
so what the [ __ ] am i saying right
it's like he cannot be funny to me but
he's still funny though dude
dane's a beast yeah and there's a lot of
comics especially in my circle who hate
dane cook
really i came in after and dane's always
been [ __ ] great to me man so i stick
up for him he's a [ __ ]
he's so talented dude you you'll hear
patrice talk about this bill burt talked
about this
rogan talked about this when they all
came up in boston yep there was the
[ __ ] hub
and no one wanted to follow dan cook the
[ __ ] he was doing dude
monster i dude i've seen him do just
there's there's these two
uh basically strippers at the common
store in the main room and dane was on
and every comic went into the background
like those [ __ ] girls man in the
front
season comics every comic i went on
they're louder my set i'm like
i just powered through it ignored them
they're so loud they're disrupting
everything
and as i go off uh i have to bring on
dane
and uh dangerous which ones are they and
he picks up here is this [ __ ] two
right there he goes
cool oh [ __ ] dude he goes out there and
he just starts doing his thing
they go beep dude for
30 minutes straight with some of the
best material you've ever heard off the
top of the dome
he lit them up so bad they walked out
the whole crowd stands up
clapping damn i was like that's not
gonna make professional doug
professional i mean you went from from
finding the stand-up i mean i don't even
know how that happens
like i don't know like there's oh
i've always wanted to do stand up and my
way into it was meeting brian kellen
getting
and then doing pot of comedy podcasts so
me and brian would do
live firing the kids but it wasn't a
live podcast suck dude
brian's doing now but whatever um
shout out to big and hungry i love you
guys but live podcasts are a disaster
but me and brian used to do it
but it was a performance so brian i'd be
like dude i'm not doing live podcast
i've seen those are so boring he's like
no
dude we're going to use our fan base and
then every show we start with you're
going to do 10 minutes
yeah you're going to start every show
with 10 minutes so that's how you
understand that that's
that's when i met you guys yep live yeah
you guys were doing the live podcast
is there a lot of pressure i mean even
for all you guys like for example
uh because you've been put on by joe
rogan and a lot of these great comics
right yeah and
like i said like i know of your work i
know what you do i know what people say
yeah
so is there a lot of pressure for for
you to do
better than what people expect out of
you because a lot of people feel that
you've been kind of put on a platform
because a lot of people have pushed you
up there
to be at a certain place because i feel
like that's a lot of pressure right
i don't feel the pressure i feel like uh
so
rogan delia bryan theo
uh joey santino bobby lee you can go
through the entire whitney cummings the
entire list of these monster comics
they're not going to cosign if i wasn't
funny i'm not going to sell every show
on the road
multiple times in multiple cities year
after year if i wasn't funny
so again that that online chatter is not
real dude
it's not really about what happens on
the stage in the crowd again ticket
sales
podcast views you know bank account
that's all real i can
i can see that in black and white i
don't care about anything else i feel no
pressure
i feel no pressure you have a very
strong mentality why do you not do you
not feel that
you would you you would have to what
else am i yeah what am i going to do
what else would you do that's true what
you're out if you have a special i'll
listen to you if you're a
legit comic torn comic like i am if you
sell more takes than me i'll listen to
you so how did you feel about the
critique about your special then
like uh from don't see it damn man
you're man you got the blinders on son
that's good i don't see it but you're
coming with the questions today
no i love it because yeah but the as far
as special so
it depends like i probably too early to
do it probably two
you know only two years in stamp doing
specials crazy because for me too right
because i
i became a fan of watching you on the
podcast scene right sure so when i saw
you do the special i also felt it was a
little too early for you
you know because early for sure yeah
because you know two years in that's
mad fast you know so when here's my
question for you
in the haters to say this what would you
do if
every outlet name name a show offered
you a special
in a half an hour what would you do
you're gonna not do it
what are you gonna do and then yeah you
don't know me like that love you don't
know me like that
big [ __ ] bro and then and then that
special parlayed into every other thing
i do with showtime which i have a
multi-year deal with
and then okay and then yeah yeah so yeah
so the haters didn't it didn't hurt you
so it's like hey what put that dick on
this table real quick right now
so but then also after that like now i
have pressure
i have offers from any big company you
know to shoot another special that's
awesome
so what do you want me to do
this is you know what i'm saying so it's
like i don't know what you do damn
yeah you're a wise sage i mean you kind
of have to be to
go through all that because i think it's
interesting as well
like the amount of just like [ __ ] hey
he's just like
it doesn't make sense because i go like
we go on the road with you and the shows
are sold out and people are
[ __ ] ecstatic they're like like
they're excited to see you but when you
think about
hate you probably again they're the
loudest in the room yeah so it's 300
losers who are in their mom's basement
oh this guy ain't [ __ ] watching those
guys [ __ ]
i bet you would trade your life with me
you know what i'm saying oh 100 yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh one 100 if you've got a drink any of
them
if any
he's just he's just where he's at
because rogan put him on you know many
people rogan's put on
you know how many people yeah how many
how many people has rogan put on
i can give you a [ __ ] plethora
of [ __ ] people and they ain't doing
[ __ ] but you also had to work hard for
that sellout because i remember when we
had stevo on
he was saying too like he was like yeah
my name i'm stevo but he goes i wasn't
selling out shows immediately
like it just doesn't work that way like
how many doesn't work how many doesn't
work yeah
doesn't work that way like you have to
work your ass off to be
a ticket sale how about that when i get
off stage with the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son